[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and throughout this video
we're going to be going over the new
trailer for halloween ends the first
teaser for the film has just dropped and
the slasher slash horror movie has a lot
to impact from it throughout this video
i want to go over all the details that
we learned from this new look as well as
what we know about the film in general
there will be some minor spoilers here
in regards to the plot as well as some
rumors on the film so if you don't want
to know anything then check out now
please hit the thumbs up button if
you're sticking with us and without the
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into halloween ends
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so this is due to be the final film
in the david gordon green trilogy and
it'll see laurie strode facing off
against michael myers one last time
groovy baby kind of feel like she must
be like this at this point after going
against him 700 times now in alternate
timelines and this one will probably be
ratcon 2 in about two weeks time either
way up top i think it's important to say
that this is taking place four years
after halloween kills obviously they
want to bring the characters up to
present day rather than keeping them in
2018 which is where halloween also
titled halloween was set lori has had
four long years to recover and she's
likely also turned herself even more
into rambo due to the gap between the
movies you might remember that in the
prior two that her house burned down so
this one we see in the opening shot is
likely her new one it's adorned with
jack-o'-lanterns pitch black in there
and up the stairs awaits laurie with a
handgun to give this a proper reunion
now there's a lot of theories floating
around about how this film will be about
copycats and duplicate michaels looking
at the teaser with that in mind a lot of
things make way more sense including how
one seems to be killed by lorry he's not
putting up as much of a fight and
there's also the fact that he just
wanders in without a second thought now
we don't know this for definite so take
it with a pinch of salt but this derives
from the fact that there's been
discussions on how we'll see many
versions of michael in this movie
halloween kills was of course laced with
social commentary and this final film
could be poking fun at how many movies
copied the halloween mold with their own
killers there are definitely versions of
michael that looks slightly different in
this first look and though it could turn
out to be untrue i thought i'd talk
about that up top as one of the main
things around the film hopefully we will
see a william shatnervation in this film
with the actor playing the role and we
can finally bring everything full circle
now fret not halloween fans because
michael will be returning which we get
confirmed by this new look the teaser
culminates with lori grabbing a knife
and stabbing him through the hand you
can see that his fingers are missing
which definitely confirms that this one
at the very least is from the prior
movies his mask also has a greenish tint
to it whereas the one earlier in this
new look looks more intact now the
opening of this tea set is very much
putting us in the shoes of michael and
the original film of course opened with
a long scene from his point of view
that's clearly why this has been brought
in two and it immediately brings back
those old school vibes to bring
everything together you also get
breathing over the top of this
now this is also accompanied by the
oldest style score showing how this is
kind of going back to its roots kills
was very very over the top in terms of
its well kills and the creative team
behind this one have stated how they're
trying to go back to basics and paint
michael out more as the shape rather
than the terminator that he turned into
this is clear from the teaser which uses
several shots from the prior movies now
it's important to bear in mind that this
is also a slightly different teaser to
what was shown at cinemacon that had a
lot more texts talking about how 44
years ago the face of fear was born it
also had a clip of lori hiding in a
cupboard which of course calls back to
the first film however the fight that we
see was shown at the event so we are
getting some snippets of it a huge shout
out to jimmy champagne for spotting that
the opening of this teaser is similar to
the opening of halloween six obviously
they wreck on the universe but kills was
filled with homages to halloween too and
it looks like they're gonna at least
acknowledge those timelines through
shots like this also jimmy runs a great
youtube channel just centered around
halloween so if you're interested in the
movies then definitely go head over
there after this to kill him go and kill
him now he's a lovely guy and actually
one of the first youtubers i ever spoke
to so definitely go show him some love
now we also spot that there's the kid in
the old school sailor suit that also
appeared in the one shot in the prior
movies the opening kind of flips
everything on its head as we have a
michael that thinks he's closing in on
laurie but instead she's got the drop on
him don't know how she misses but
hopefully she can hit the subscribe
button give me a rent now one of my
favorite details in this new look is
that laurie is wearing the exact same
clothes as she had on in the original
halloween movie this is obviously going
to be going back to basics as well so
her wearing this sort of cements that
idea and brings everything full circle
keep using that word but that's exactly
what they're doing
her room is filled with newspaper
clippings on the wall and this shows
that she's still just obsessed with the
man of her dreams as she always was i
know this might not be laurie's house
but seeing those clippings made me think
that it is you also get a shot of alison
who is apparently going to take a big
focus in the movie being said that she's
going to get some major attention in
this entry and with her mother dying in
the last one that the thrust of the
story will be centered around her laurie
is apparently taking a bit of a backseat
and it is interesting that we don't
really see her all that much outside of
this fight scene does she die well i
hope not as laurie is the final girl's
final girl but we'll just have to see
what they decide to do now alison of
course also brings across several new
victims in the form of her friends the
last movie was very much all about
lorries getting wiped out along with her
daughter so it makes sense that they'd
have to find victims from somewhere else
however one person that does still
return is officer hawkins who is back
along with the boys in blue we then get
a montage of all the prior movies in
this saga before ending on the fight
between laurie and michael that kind of
brings things to a close and at this
point i want to talk about the other
plot leaks around the movie that are
likely untrue judging by this new look
gonna give you a couple of seconds to
bounce just in case you don't want to
know them at all but i actually think
this teaser debunks them and paints them
out to be untrue i'm just basically
doing this bit so if you've heard those
plot leaks i can be like well you're
wrong you're wrong you're wrong are you
still here cool so it was said that
michael would die within the first 15
minutes and that it would twist
everything on its head i don't think
they'll do that for a number of reasons
namely because it's stupid but there's
also different times of night that
appear in this trailer you can tell due
to the way that things are lit that we
go deeper into the night and yet i just
can't really see that happening because
of how much you would the fans there's
no way they could do that in a
satisfying way that provides an end to
both lori and alison's storyline and i
just hope they avoid that at all costs i
can see them making maybe one of her
friends a michael copycat but beyond
that i think the main one will remain
behind and who knows he might even kill
the doppelgangers now as for my thoughts
on the teaser i'm not sure what to
really make of it as there's very little
to go on it does seem to be recapturing
the look and feel of the original
halloween and the 2018 movie which is
probably a smart move due to how
divisive that kills was i'm actually in
the camp of being someone that liked
that movie and i wish michael would just
kill me whenever it's brought up because
hey not many people do but yeah
hopefully this restores people's faith
for the final one as it has a lot
resting on its shoulders all the legacy
casts are getting to the point now where
they probably can't reboot it again and
i'm not even sure they should the
timeline of this is so messy at this
point that it's confusing even trying to
approach the franchise so hopefully this
is the last one halloween ends and we
can go out on a high for the final entry
i am tempering my expectations but as
far as first teasers go this was pretty
solid didn't spoil too much but also set
things up nicely
and yeah that's kind of what you want
from a first look i'd of course love to
hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know we are
on a competition right now giving away
three copies of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications son and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on
twitter.heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the full
marvel slate which will be linked on
screen right now you go over all the
confirmed and rumored upcoming projects
so definitely head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video hope you
enjoyed it take care yourself peace